so who's a dreamer us to you - usually
everybody that was brought to the newest
and youngest members because you're
undocumented
how old were you when you came did you
tell your mom hey mom I wanna go us I
mean without you no no I couldn't find
out now some that Vincent I'm told I
want to turn this
and you in the option that the recruiter
gave me was like well you can marry me
some people want to take advantage of
the situation but I don't want to do
that I don't want to marry because of
that and it's like is that my only
option and I know that it's reality to a
lot of women like me because we in a way
we don't have a voice because we we
don't have a security number we can vote
we can't do a lot of things if she wants
to go to college she wants to help out
the American economy the American
community she's an American she wasn't
born on this side of the river but she's
an American our president has dropped
any protections that keep these kids
from being deported but where would they
go I've never lived anywhere else even
some of his supporters think that's
they've got a right to be here they do
it wasn't their choice to come to the US
it was their mother's choice that
brought them here as far as I'm
concerned they're part of our society
[Music]